hunger hardship and in desperate need of
help
almost two months into a new taliban
regime and the people of afghanistan are
hurting the situation is clearly getting
worse and by the end of the year
we're projecting that 22.8 million
that's 55 percent of the population more
than one of uh more than one out of
every two afghans will be acutely food
insecure we'll be experiencing hunger on
a daily basis
it's not the legacy british and american
troops would have wanted to leave after
20 years of war
tough questions then for the defense
secretary from mps investigating the
withdrawal i don't think we were
defeated
i think if we had chosen to stay as the
force we had
or indeed if we wanted to continue we
were
our resolve was found wanting in what i
would say rather than defeated i think
the difference is nato were there to
enable a camp a political resolution a
political campaign
and i think that is what failed
in a limited success the uk did manage
to evacuate thousands of afghans out of
kabul airport before the taliban took
over
among them was imtiaz who worked for the
british government and is still haunted
by what he witnessed while waiting for a
flight this scenario of a father taking
his daughter to safety and while she
died of suffocation and holding her in
her hand that is one memory that i may
never forget in my lifetime while safe
imtiaz is now stuck in limbo in a hotel
with his wife and two daughters still
waiting for a home at least we should
have some communication from the home
office from the government or the
council to what is the
next step we are still lacking the
information from that's what everybody
is asking how does the housing work
evidence that even the uk's rescue
mission from afghanistan is at risk of
failure debra haynes sky news